You know, it's funny how some
families have these stories, or
maybe not even stories, just
patterns, things that kind of
hum through the wall.
Oh absolutely.
Like an unspoken vibe almost.
You feel it even if nobody talks
about it directly.
Exactly.
And that feeling, that subtle
hum, is actually right where
we're starting this deep dive.
We're getting into a concept the
source essay calls Manufactured
Descent.
Right.
And you know, if you're
immediately thinking Q Anon or
Russian bots, this essay argues
it goes way deeper, much older.
Yeah, it's not just digital
noise.
It's about how real old grief's
actual historical pain get
deliberately, you know, stoked
back into a flame.
When someone needs cheap fuel,
that's the phrase the essay
uses.
It's quite chilling, really.
It is.
And the essay we're looking at
today, it leaves this idea
through personal stories,
history.
Yeah, uses some really potent
metaphors.
Definitely.
So our mission really is to
unpack those core metaphors, the
ghosts, the coal seams, and this
idea of the switchboard.
Trying to understand how that
ancestral pain, that real
suffering, can be sort of
harnessed and redirected.
Without people even realizing
their own history is being used
that way so for.
You listening?
We want to make this clear and
quick, give you those aha
moments about how these things
shape our world, your world,
without it feeling like a
lecture.
Yeah, it's not just academic.
It's about seeing those
floorboards humming, maybe in
your own life or just out there
in the world.
So where does the essay start?
It kicks off with a really
personal story, doesn't it,
About family?
It does it talks about the
author's pop pop moving Nana to
a dead end Rd.
Spring Lake, NJ The.
Idea of being.
To stop her reaching the bar,
basically keep her away from the
bottle.
But as the essay puts it, the
bottle always finds its way.
She'd drink, get furious, use
the phone, dial in that, rage
out.
Half real, half imagined, all
unstoppable betrayal is how the
author frames it.
Yeah, and the key line there you
can build a cul-de-sac to trap a
body, but a ghost always finds
the switchboard.
Wow.
OK, so that switchboard idea
comes in early.
And how does that connect to the
author's own childhood?
Well, they describe their
childhood soundtrack as ice
cubes against cheap glass.
Mom's whiskey.
Dad's gym.
Held together by drinking, the
essay suggests.
And a kind of silent agreement
not to poke at the ghosts too
much.
You know the family history.
Parish famine, Hungarian
fascists, all that stuff.
Exactly.
Beat cops, boarding houses,
generations of it.
Even moving to Hawaii didn't
silence it.
The ghosts were patient.
Humming under the floorboards,
rattling the pipes still there.
So how do we get from this very
personal family hum to say
global conflicts?
Is there a bridge?
A metaphor.
Yes, and it's central, the coal
metaphor.
Pain as buried carbon.
OK, explain that a bit.
They give historical traumas,
genocide, slavery, famine, like
ancient carbon deposits we build
over them.
Call it progress.
New towns on top.
Pretend it's dealt with
sequestered right?
But the essay's point is
crucial.
Buried carbon is only dormant
until someone wants to feed
oxygen to the seam.
It's waiting and someone can
choose to light it.
Precisely.
And that's where you see these
ancestral coal seams being
stoked internationally.
Like in Ukraine, The essay
tackles that.
It does.
It contrasts the sort of bedtime
version we often get.
Democracy versus tyrant, good
guys versus bad guys.
Simple narrative.
With a deep coal seam underneath
the Holodome war, Stalin's
famine in the 30s, millions
starved.
And that's not just history.
According to the essay, it
lives.
Exactly in whispers and fears
about Moscow taking the bread,
that ghost, it argues, waited
until someone knew how to stoke
it.
And the stocking part.
How does the essay frame
external influence, say from the
West?
It's quite direct.
Suggests the US didn't invent
the wound, obviously, but quote
we sure as hell knew how to dial
it.
Dialing the ghost via the
switchboard.
Promises of never again NATO
protection, fighting Stalin's
ghost.
Yeah, just enough oxygen, the
essay implies, to push things
towards conflict.
Towards a grinder they can't win
is the phrase used.
Yes, the original trauma.
The carbon is real.
The switchboard just connects
the match.
Now, the essay is very careful
here about not excusing current
aggression.
Extremely careful, it explicitly
states this is not an apology
for Putin's slaughter.
Not a soft word for the Kremlin.
It's.
An accusation.
Aimed at anyone who looks at
someone else's ancestral pain
and says that'll burn nicely.
It's about the manipulation of
trauma.
OK, so that's one example.
How does this play out with
something like soft power?
Less overt conflict?
Hawaii is the key example there.
The author grew up with it.
The stolen Kingdom, the sugar
barons, the Navy bases.
It was no.
A ghost that slept.
A quiet rage.
Yeah, something simmering in
families at gatherings.
The sovereignty movement existed
but often lacked oxygen.
A buried scene.
So what happens when the
switchboard plugs into that?
It's not a physical phone line
anymore, is it?
Right now it's hashtags,
Instagram protests, Ted talks.
Duolingo offering Hawaiian
lessons.
While hedge funds buy up Maui.
The grief is real, absolutely,
but the switchboard dials it
into.
Virtue points.
Tourist skill.
The soft glow of empire
laundering its sins, as the
essay puts it, and the hinge the
crucial.
Part the carbon burns, but the
people still can't afford to
live there.
Exactly.
The energy is consumed, but the
root issue persists.
That's powerful.
OK, this leads to me the most
sensitive example.
The Shoah, The Holocaust.
How does the essay approach
Never Again?
Very carefully.
It calls the Shoah, the
nightmare that eats all the
bedtime stories, a trauma that
lives everywhere.
Synagogues.
Friday nights, Tel Aviv bunkers,
checkpoints.
The fear is undeniable.
Real translates to never again.
Of course, and the essay
acknowledges, never again is
vital.
Like a guard dog, it can also
become a hired gun, the same
carbon that vigilance can be
used to justify walls,
checkpoints, bulldozers, bombs.
It's the echo, the essay says.
You'll never be cattle again.
Right and the machine.
Politicians, arms dealers,
ideologues, They know how to
stoke that echo.
Dial the ghost at the right
moment.
So again, the trauma isn't fake,
the grief is real.
Absolutely not fake, but it
makes it vulnerable.
That's the core point.
No one is safe from the
switchboard.
And this applies elsewhere to
the essay mentions.
The white working class in
America?
Yeah, floorboards humming with
the Depression, lost factories,
the 2008 bailout, humiliation.
When the banks got saved and
they didn't, right?
The algorithm knows that seem
people whisper about replacement
betrayal.
Same dynamic stocking the
embers.
And the author brings it back
home personally, even after
quitting drinking.
The pipe still hums manifests
differently overeating,
overthinking, late night
writing, so the.
Ghost isn't just the past event.
It's the open line, the
vulnerability.
If you don't guard it, someone
else will dial it.
U reroute it, sell you
something.
And the switchboards themselves
have evolved from Nanas old
phone line.
Oh yeah.
Now it's smartphones, TikTok,
maybe a well meaning NGO that
wants you to speak your truth.
As long as it comes with
hashtags and donations.
Potentially, yes.
And the author is clear.
I'm not better than this.
I'm not outside it.
We're all part of it.
We're all switchboards too.
OK, let's drill down into some
of the concepts here.
The essay mentions epigenetics.
Can you unpack that a bit?
How does it make people easy to
hook?
Sure, it's not pop psychology,
it's biology.
How major stressors, famine,
terror can literally change how
your genes express themselves.
Not the DNA code itself, but how
it works.
So stress responses can be
inherited in a way.
Yeah, descendants might
metabolize fear differently,
react more strongly, makes them
potentially easier to, well,
hook when those old traumas are
triggered.
Think Dutch hunger, winter
children of Showa, survivors,
descendants of enslaved people.
Doesn't doom you, but.
Makes the floorboards hum
louder, maybe more resonant.
Gotcha.
And how is manufactured descent
different from Tomsky's
manufactured consent?
Good question.
Consent is about propaganda for
passivity, getting people to
agree or just go along.
Descent is the flip.
You activate old grievances,
stir up the rage that's already
there, and then aim it.
So consent is about quiet
agreement.
Descent is about directed anger.
Exactly.
Suffering in manufactured
descent is real.
The manipulation lies in the
deliberate provocation and
redirection.
Which makes the switchboard the
absolute key metaphor.
It's the the control panel.
Yeah, the hub.
The line that lets the ghost
dial out, connecting that
personal or group pain to a
bigger current, amplifying and
steering it, often for someone
else's benefit.
And soft power is a tool for
that switchboard, just to recap
its role.
It's the indirect influence,
culture, education, aid apps,
the friendly face that can still
reroute the ghost channel
grievances in subtle ways.
And finally, that carbon
sequestration idea ties it all
together.
Ancestral trauma as buried fuel.
Right.
Like coal or oil, it can lie
dormant for ages.
But once you dig it up and burn
it, stoke those old wounds, it
poisons the atmosphere all over
again, causes new harm, new
conflicts.
OK, super important.
What is this essay not saying?
Let's be crystal clear on the
disclaimers it makes itself.
Crucial point.
First, it does not blame
victims.
It says trauma makes you
vulnerable to being baited.
Doesn't dismiss real grief
either.
No, but it urges you to see when
grief is being repackaged and
sold back to you.
The pain is valid, the
manipulation isn't.
And politically regarding
Ukraine or the Shoah?
It's explicit, not pro Putin,
not anti Ukraine.
Focuses on how wounds get used
by those who benefit.
And not anti Jewish or both
sides of Jing of the Holocaust.
Correct, it affirms never again,
but points out how even that
truth could be tempting fuel for
those profiting from a siege
mentality.
The critique is always aimed at
the manipulators.
So wrapping up, this isn't a
sermon, the essay says.
It's an elegy.
An elegy for the carbon we can't
seem to keep buried.
The ghost never dies, but maybe
we don't have to feed it to the
same machine generation after
generation.
Some ghosts want a memorial,
some a closed door.
Some just want to stay asleep.
The key is knowing which is
which for ourselves.
Which really puts the question
to you listening.
What are your floorboards
humming with?
What's your switchboard
connected to?
Yeah, because, the essay warns,
every coal seam you feed burns
someone's lungs.
In the end, we need to recognize
that not every seam needs to
burn forever.
Maybe we can choose differently.
And we'll leave you with that
closing blessing from the source
text.
Something to Mull over.
May you know your ghosts, may
you witness them, but not sell
them cheap.
May you watch the floorboards
hum, but keep your switchboard
guarded.
May you drink the whole bottle
of your own story, not the boxed
wine your enemies would sell you
in its place.